MALE SPEAKER: Hello, everyone.
Welcome back.
We have two more sessions
left today.
The first one here is
Understanding Your Players
Using Near Real Time
Game Analytics.
And this is going to be Michael
Manoochehri from
Google, that search
company you've
probably never heard of.
And then we also have, from
Staq, Luca joining us to talk
about how they've used Google
BigQuery to build their game
analytics solution.
So they're going to be starting
here in just a
second, but then the last
session that starts at 4:30 is
going to be How EA Builds Mobile
Game Servers On Google
App Engine.
So hope you can all stick around
for both of these, and
welcome, guys.
LUCA MARTINETTI: Hello.
Can you hear me?
Hi.
I am Luca Martinetti.
I'm the CTO of Staq.
Staq is a brand new startup
that started in TechStars.
Today, it's a three-man army.
It's me and these two guys here,
Massimo and Francesco.
We had a big vision.
We tried to build a game
management platform, and I'll
try to explain a little
bit better what we
believe this means.
Today, I'll be talking about how
to understand your players
using analytics, and how to
do that in real time.
And I have to say thank you,
Google, for having us here.
That's because we use a big
chunk of their analytics
offering, BigQuery.
So you are a game developer,
so you'll probably want to
build a game.
You're here to build a game.
And what I'll say is no.
No more.
No more games.
You're not shipping
boxes anymore.
The market is so changed.
What you're actually doing is
you're building a service.
Building a service
is very different
from shipping a product.
It has a complete different set
of challenges and requires
different state of mind and
different procedures.
Building a service means that
it's always on 24/7.
Somebody's always interactive
with your game and generating
events, generating data.
At a certain point, if
you're successful--
and that's a problem you want to
have-- you understand that
you're sitting on a giant
data fire hose.
Spoiler--
in this fire hose, there are so
many interesting things you
want to learn, you want
to try to grasp.
In order to do that, we believe
you should set up a
process made of three steps.
Measure something, so collect
the data, try to understand
something you don't know
before, and react.
React in a way that can make
your game better or your
monetizaton stream better.
So actually your life better.
Yeah, the three guys there are
us, looking at the big screen,
and this is the flow we want
to enable at Staq.
So starting from an event that
could be in an upper trace,
try to understand something new
through analytics and data
analysis, and then react somehow
with a promotion or
with a discount, with a game
change, and so on.
So today, trying to explain a
little bit more in detail how
to collect data in the right
way, and how important it is
to have a way of running queries
very efficiently.
Because these are, at the end,
the two important steps that
will enable all the rest
of the process.
So collecting data, what you
want to collect, what you want
to measure.
It depends.
There are so many options.
Some of those are game-specific,
some are common
to different kind of games.
What is important is that you
should try to collect a piece
of information that happens in
a certain point in time that
is an event.
That's the JSON schema
that we use.
What's happening here is that
at this timestamp, in this
[INAUDIBLE] game, this was this
warrior that was at level
seven, and with these two and
a big sword was raging and
hitting somebody, and
create some damage.
So this is a typical event you
want to collect from, again.
And using Staq, you're not
enforced to any specific
schema, and we'll talk about
that more in detail later.
So you start collecting these
guys, and you figure out that
you have tons of data.
What does it mean?
It depends.
It depends greatly on the
traffic you have, on how much
your instrument in your game.
But if you're successful,
if your player base is
significant, at a certain point,
you'll have to manage
gigabytes per hour.
This means that many of the
solutions that classical
architecture with a MySQL
database are not good anymore.
Not good anymore for
the amount of
data and the velocity.
And there are some caveats, some
very important things you
have to consider.
And this is the biggest one,
that you cannot pre-aggregate.
It means that you cannot
take just some piece of
information, increment
counters.
You need to keep the raw
data, all of it.
Why?
Because at a certain point,
you'll come up with new
questions that you didn't have
beforehand, or you have new
data points that will make
extremely different the story
of a player, for example.
Say you're using an advertising
network, and at a
certain point in time, you
receive the list of the
players you bought from
that specific channel.
So you need to reconcile
this data with
your history of events.
So you need a system that can
handle tons of data in the raw
form because that will allow you
to ask new questions over
time and integrate the new data
points when they come.
I'll talk about the kind of data
we're also building to
offer our analytics
platform and the
tech solution we chose.
We're so proud of what we're
building that we chose this
double buzz word, the
real-real-time.
That means two time real time.
Why that?
Because we ended up choosing
to use two different data
stores for answering
the same questions.
We're building a system that
allows you to run the very
same exact queries on two
different databases that have
some different performance
profiles and allows you to
have always the freshest data
available, and at the same
time, run analyses and run the
same queries on all your
historical data set.
So if your game has been around
for one year, you want
to be able to answer a
question about what's
happening now and
how this trend
developed in the last year.
We're building on top
of two technologies
that are very different.
One of that is a database
that is called MemSQL.
That is an in-memory
version of MySQL.
It's a startup as well.
It's here in San Francisco,
a YC startup.
That is pretty cool, because
it keeps all the data in
memory and allows you to do
very fast aggregation.
At the same time, we're using
this excellent product from
Google that is called
BigQuery.
That is a database as service,
you could say, for analytics
that allows you to run queries
real fast on gigabytes of
data, or terabytes, without
having to manage the whole
infrastructure.
Our design goal was to be
awesome fast on the latest
buffer of data.
So it depends on the size of
your game, but it could be the
last day or last week's, and be
really, really fast on all
the historical analysis.
What we love about BigQuery is
that, as I was saying, it
offers us a service.
And if you're a three-man
company, like us, not having
to manage a big cluster,
like an Hadoop
cluster, for example.
Even if it runs on a cloud
provider, it's a big win,
because you just take a service
and you know it will
be working, at night, 3:00 AM.
It allows you to do fast ad
hoc queries on large data
sets, and that's a very nice
feature that is called nested
fields that allows us to
manage the TOCs that we
associate with every event.
So it's a little bit broader in
the data definition than a
row of a table in a database.
It's as fast that sometimes you
don't understand how much
data you're touching, and the
pricing model is actually
based on the amount of data
your queries are touching.
So I was running a demo
a few months ago,
and that's what happened.
I ran a query on two terabytes
of data, and I said, what?
Because that's what you
see in the bill.
So it's so fast that you really
don't understand how
much data you're touching
in a single query.
And so we love it,
and when the bill
came, I was like this.
Let me introduce Michael, and
then we'll talk more about the
query, and I'll continue
later.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Awesome.
Thank you, Luca.
Can you guys all hear me?
Yeah?
That sounds like a yes.
Yeah, so I'm going to do my best
"Futurama" Fry impression
and say I don't know if I'm
happy to see grumpy cat or sad
that it was used in the same
sentence as BigQuery.
But anyway, I'll talk a little
bit about how to integrate the
BigQuery API into your
application.
For those of you who don't know,
BigQuery is an API that
lets you ask questions
about large data
sets, your own data.
I'm not going to get too deep
into the technical details.
I'm actually going to show
you how it works.
BigQuery is an API in which you
can send messages to it in
JSON format and then retrieve
query results in JSON as well,
which makes it really easy to
incorporate into your existing
applications.
And what I really like about the
Staq story is they've got
their existing application.
I think you build mostly in the
cloud, and it's easy to
integrate BigQuery
with that system.
So they really understand the
kind of modern data pipeline
where you have a particular
technology for collecting data
in real time very quickly, and
being able to ask questions
about that real time data that's
coming in, and then
asking quick questions about
historical data or aggregate
data that takes a
different tool.
And so what Staq's done really
well is integrate two
different tools on top
of their web stack.
The best way to show you, if
you've never seen BigQuery
before, is how it works
and how to integrate.
I have an example here.
I tried to build the simplest--
let me see if I can
make this a little
bit bigger--
the simplest application
that I could using
the BigQuery API.
All of the Google APIs that are
built on our modern stack
have client libraries
in many languages.
We've got Ruby, and Java, and
JavaScript, and Python, PHP,
just about everything
you need.
And we have open source projects
of people building
other things because it's
just a RESTful API.
It's easy to integrate.
So this is an example of some
code I wrote just really
quickly using BigQuery with
the JavaScript API.
And what I'm doing here-- and
I'm just showing you sort of
what it looks like, how little
code you need to run a query
on a very massive data set.
In this case, I have a client ID
and a project ID that I got
from the Google Developers
Console.
This is something you can
kind of read about on
the BigQuery website.
I don't have a lot of time
to get into that part.
And I've integrated it into
this application.
I've chosen a scope for
authorization of the API.
And simply, what I'm doing is
I'm just running a query, and
that query will come
from a box.
And I'll show you this
application in a second.
And then visualizing that data,
the response from that
query, with a chart.
So let me show you
how this works.
Oh, are we offline?
We might actually be offline.
LUCA MARTINETTI: Offline demo?
Let's try again.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: One moment,
please, while we make
sure the network's right.
LUCA MARTINETTI:
What happened?
We can try just switch
to Wi-Fi.
What do you think?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: All right,
let's give that a shot.
Great.
Yeah, it looks like we had
a network [? conflict. ?]
OK.
So is what the app looks like.
It's really simple.
It has an authorization
button.
I've actually run
through this.
It's doing an OAuth 2.0
authorization, but as you saw,
the client library's taking
care of a lot of the
complexity.
And now here's a query.
I'm going to use a sample
that we have in
our public data samples.
When you sign up for BigQuery,
we have a collection of really
large data sets for
you to try it out.
And so what I'm doing here is
I'm sending it a SQL-like
query, and what's great about
BigQuery, it combines a lot of
the best of technologies from
big data applications.
So when you're dealing with
gigabytes and terabytes of
data, often you turn to
MapReduce-based tools like
Hadoop, data warehousing tools
like Hive, or you're using a
NoSQL data source, something
like Mongo.
BigQuery doesn't use a
MapReduce-based paradigm.
We actually have a different
kind of execution model.
Basically we store your data in
a columnar format, and then
we do most of the actual
aggregation in memory across a
very large cluster.
So actually what you're getting
with BigQuery is our
own infrastructure.
But what's cool about it is you
can ask questions, not by
writing MapReduce functions, but
in a SQL-like language, so
it makes it very easy
to iterate.
So in this example, in this
application that you just saw
the code for, I'm going
to ask a question
about our GitHub timeline.
The GitHub timeline data, by the
way, is a public data set
that GitHub provides of any
repository that's public.
So here, I'm asking what are
the top five languages that
get the most events?
So let's just run that.
Hopefully everything
will work fine.
In fact, I'm going to pull up
in the developer console so
you can see what the response
looks like.
So here's an example.
That was a very quick query.
This is actually a fairly
large data set.
There's 30 million
records in here.
And almost instantly, it
returned this table, and this
is what the response looks
like on the JSON side.
I don't know if you can see
that, but it's basically just
a JSON representation of
the table you see.
So it's very easy
to integrate.
You saw that small
amount of code.
I'm able to build a dashboard
that's querying this really
interesting data set to show you
how you can integrate this
into your applications.
But let's talk about doing
this with games.
What kind of queries are really
good for game things?
I was thinking about some
queries that might appeal to
some people coming to GDC, and
when you talk about games,
you're often talking about
cohort analysis.
So here's another example of a
public data set that we have.
Hopefully you can see this.
I'll make it a little bit bigger
so you can see it.
We're going to look at the
Wikipedia revision
history data sets.
So this is a very large
data set that we have.
It's 35 gigs.
It's got 300 million records.
And let me see if I can
actually zoom in
a little bit here.
Is that a little bit better?
Can you see that, everyone?
So basically, there's 35 gigs.
It's pretty big.
It's got 300 million records,
and the data kind
of looks like this.
It's got a title.
It has a timestamp.
And a contributor ID, like who
revised the article, what
their contributor's name was.
So I was thinking about some
queries we could run to kind
of demonstrate what a cohort
analysis would look like, and
so I have some examples here.
The first thing, I was thinking
about people's names,
and I realized people like to
name themselves "Wikipedia,"
like to name themselves like
"Wikipedia Mage" and
"Wikipedia Wizard," much like
some of the gamers that you
have on social media.
So the first query I thought of
was this cohort analysis.
I wanted to see what usernames
contained these strings.
So I wrote us a very simple
SQL-like query here, and it
should go pretty quickly.
So in seven seconds, it did a
full table scan of all 300
million records, and it found
some matches that look a lot
like "mage." And you can
see images in there.
So that was very quick.
There's 283,000 records.
I wanted to do an
ad hoc analysis.
I wanted to iterate quickly.
Now if I was doing this with
MapReduce, I'd have to write a
new MapReduce function.
I'd have to do a new workflow.
It takes time.
What I want to do is just ask
these quick questions on this
huge data set very quickly.
The first thing I want
to do is get rid
of those image results.
So I'm going to do a regular
expression match, which
BigQuery supports.
So what I'm doing here is I'm
running the same query--
and actually, let me
take this out.
I'll do this in a second.
So I'm running the same query,
but what I'm doing here is I'm
saying instead of the contain
string, I'll do a regular
expression match on "wizard"
or "mage."
So I'm going to run this again,
and hopefully what will
happen is that I'll see the
real user names that don't
have the word "image." So we
have Pharaoh of the Wizards,
and Wizard191.
So now I'm getting somewhere,
like I'm building a cohort
analysis where I'm actually
looking at a
particular type of user.
Now what I want to do is bucket
my results by a time.
I want to see who's doing what
on a particular day.
Again, this is going over 35
gigs, and imagine doing this
on something like MySQL
Datastore or
something like that.
It would take a long time, but
I'm doing these queries in
four seconds.
So I'll do another
quick query.
Let's see, I'll run another
sample that's similar.
Now let's add a time bucket,
and I'll just run through
these really quick.
What I'm going to do here is
I'm going to say, use the
function call UTC USEC TO_DAY,
which means it'll take any
timestamp it sees and bucket
it in a 24-hour period.
Basically what I'm doing is I'm
saying, give me events in
a particular day.
Segment my data like that.
So let's run this again.
What you're going to see here
is something that looks like
the same data, but events
happening per day, Wikipedia
revisions happening per day.
So that, again, took just six
seconds, and now you can see
Wizardman had done a revision
on that day.
By the way, these are
Unix timestamps.
That's why they're these
big integers
in microsecond format.
Wizardman did something
on this day.
Pharaoh of the Wizards did
something to this.
And now I'm getting somewhere.
I'm seeing what activity's
happening per day.
And now I want to do something
a little bit different.
I want to do something where I
can actually segment them as
are they wizards or
are they mages?
So I've added a conditional.
I don't know if you can see that
there, but I've added a
conditional statement that
actually segments by what type
of player or what type
of user are they.
Are they the wizard player
or the mage player?
So in just a few seconds, I
should get that as well, and
basically what this is going to
do is break that up by day.
And it's going to say how many
wizards are doing something,
how many mages are
doing something.
So here you can see, a wizard
interacted this day,
interacted that way, and I'm
able to break them up into
different mages, wizards,
warriors, what have you, based
just on their username.
And finally, let's do a final
kind of wrap it up query.
We're going to put this
all together.
We're going to group things
by wizards and mages.
We're going to add
a time bucket.
We're going to format
the timestamp.
So in just a few queries--
you can write these
very quickly and
iterate very quickly--
but I've just done a really
interesting cohort where I've
said, break it down by day.
Mages are revising only 15 times
a day, while people with
"wizard" in their username
are revising 185, and
so on, and so forth.
You can imagine taking
this data and
really breaking it down.
You could see what type
of players you have.
What are they doing.
What's their behavior.
Real quick, we've listened to
our developers, and we really
care a lot about what guys like
Luca are doing at Staq.
One thing that they've asked
us for is more features to
help them do things on
larger data sets.
Traditionally, the way that
BigQuery has designed it, it
really didn't do big joins on
different size data sets.
You could do a large data set
join to a lookup table.
But we've just a few weeks ago
released something we call Big
JOIN, which does allow
you to do these
very, very large joins.
We've done terabytes to
gigabyte data sets.
Very useful for year's worth of
activity joined with data
coming from something else,
like purchases.
And I was able to ask the Staq
team to generate a fake data
set, but something like the
data that you saw Luca
provide, which is kind of like
what their events look like.
So let me show you a little
bit about that.
Their events data looks
something like this where you
might have a particular
user ID.
It's just some hash.
A timestamp, like you saw,
they did something,
and then the event.
So in this case, this data says
that a player started at
a certain time, started
playing the game.
Another event might be
an in-app purchase.
So what if I want to ask a
question-- this particular
data set, by the way,
is 6 gigabytes.
It's about, let's see, 30
million records, right?
30 million events.
And I'm going to join this data
with another data set
that's even bigger,
something like 10
gigs, 47 million records.
I'm going to show a join, a big
join, on that, and see how
fast it can go.
And what I'm going to do is I'm
going to look for players
who started a session yesterday
or the day before,
and then bought something, had
an in-app purchase today or
the next day.
So this is a large
kind of a join.
It looks a lot like a join you
would see in a relational
database, and this is
joining data from 10
gigabytes to 6 gigabytes.
And let's see how long
this takes to run.
In here, as I mentioned, I'm
looking for in-app purchase
events that happen
in a certain day.
I'm looking for the count and
the total amount of money.
And that just took seven
seconds, so I've just did this
huge join, that's something that
you would normally do a
MapReduce job in, in
just seven seconds,
which is pretty fantastic.
And here, you've got the
aggregate queries, the count
of purchases, the amount of
money, and which user it was.
So this is the kind of cohort
analysis you can do, and you
can integrate this into your
own applications using the
BigQuery API.
I'll leave you with one more
thing before I hand it back to
Luca, and this is something
you can try
right now on your laptops.
To show this off without having
you actually develop
something or log into our
console to actually start
writing code yourself, you can
play with this using something
we call the BigQuery Tour, and
this is sort of a cartoon
exploration of two really bigger
data sets than I've
shown you today.
One is data from weather
stations all around the world
since 1929.
It's a pretty large data set.
And an even bigger data set is
a Wikipedia page views data
set, which is a really
interesting one.
Let's look at what the top page
views were for last year.
Today's the 26th, so let's see
what happened March 26.
Any guesses of what the
top Wikipedia page
viewed was a year ago?
Think about it.
I'll show you.
So I'm going to run this.
This is doing the same thing.
This is an app built on
the API, no caching.
It's hitting BigQuery's
API live.
It's crunching, and crunching.
That's actually what BigQuery
looks like inside of Google.
I don't know if you know that.
We do have ping pong balls.
So in 10 seconds we've analyzed
83 gigs of data.
Very quick.
Let's see what the
results are.
Looks like "Hunger Games!" I
guess "Hunger Games" had just
come out, so everything is
"Hunger Games." Except for
number four, Ludwig
Mies van der Rohe.
Does anyone know why he might
have had one of the fourth
largest Wikipedia page views?
It was his birthday, but we also
had a Google Doodle, and
whenever there's a Google
Doodle, the Wikipedia page
views are enormous
on that day.
So that's actually
what happened.
So there you go.
You could also look at the
queries through this.
It's really great.
You can get to this by going to
cloud.google.com/bigquery,
and you can just play
with it yourself.
Or just Google search for
"BigQuery Tour." It's probably
going to be the first hit.
So that's it.
That's what BigQuery does.
I'm going to pass it back to
Luca, and he can show you how
to integrate it into
a real app.
LUCA MARTINETTI: All right.
OK.
Yeah, the cat.
So after collecting these
events, the second step is try
to understand something that
you don't know, and this
analysis can be of very
different kinds.
There are the standard
metrics that every
single game app needs.
So daily active user, monthly
active user, revenues per
user, per paying user, and
return rates, so how long my
players are staying with me in
next day, 7 days, and 30 days.
And also these, let's say, easy
metrics, these standard
metrics, have some challenges
when I'm talking about
monetization.
For example, when I'm dealing
with in-app purchases, one of
the biggest problems that
we're facing are fake
transactions.
What does it mean?
It means that for very large
studios, if you don't do
server-side verification
of the receipts.
So if the purchase that again
is reporting to you is real,
you see just 1 in 100
transactions that is an
actual, real transaction.
And it's not as bad that you're
giving away virtual
goods, because you're not paying
for that, but your
metrics will be barely usable
with all that noise.
What has happened?
Because the devices are not
secure, and if your user base
is large enough, somebody will
spend time, nights, and hack
the game to get that great sword
for free, and you start
getting fake events.
Solution for that is having
server-side receipt
verification.
So with the Apple App Store, for
example, with Google Play,
they expose an API, so you're
not only at this point running
the game on the device.
You need a server-side part.
And that's something that Staq
provides out of the box.
What I want to show you, it's a
demo of these basic metrics.
And obviously [LAUGHS]
hope everything goes well.
I don't always test my code, so
I will do it on stage now.
So live coding.
This is the dashboard of Staq,
and what I do now is create a
new application that I've
called GDC_demo01.
And creating this application,
I will get an app ID.
All right, let's
switch to that.
I should see some nice zeroes.
And what I do is take this app
ID and just paste it into this
small Python script that is a
simulator that we call our
REST API, simulating some
events, some users logging in
and some purchases.
So let's start it.
We have connection.
It's not very popular yet.
Don't have any user.
OK.
I can see real time users
coming, and those are
generating some events.
I see some events flowing in in
real time, so some sessions
are started.
If these guys--
yeah, somebody bought
something.
I see the revenue's going up,
and I see the basic metrics in
real-real time.
So that's what I was talking
about before.
The last buffer, it's all
in-memory, so we're able to
have all these metrics, and also
custom metrics that I'll
show later, really, really
fast on your data.
And this was really quick to set
up, so if you have a game,
you just plug in our SDK.
We have, as I was saying, REST
APIs, and we also provide
Unity, JavaScript, iOS,
and an Android will be
out very, very soon.
And this is part of a story,
so understanding how much
money you're making
in a reliable way.
But that's not all.
That's not enough.
You need to ask new questions.
You need to understand
something that is
specific for your game.
As Michael was saying, are
mages spending more than
warriors if you're doing
RPG, for example?
Or are mages that reach level
seven and use this specific
sword performing better than
this other class of players?
And this can be very
arbitrary.
So why are they not buying
the dead bird?
Why?
So cute.
It's this item for "Team
Fortress 2." It's only $12.
Why are they not buying that?
I think they're actually
buying it.
So there are so many questions
that are really specific to
your game, and you need a quick
and effective way to go
against the raw data.
And I want to show something
that is even more difficult
than what I did before.
So again, demo gods,
please help us.
I have this small HTML5 game
that I found online from a guy
in Belgium.
It is a beat box.
[PERCUSSION SOUNDS]
LUCA MARTINETTI: And what I'm
going to do now is just plug
the Staq API in that and start
tracking some events.
So let me load it up.
It's just HTML5, so just a few
JavaScript files and CSS.
It runs on the canvas.
What I did is just adding the
JavaScript client of Staq of
the REST API that's
a few lines long.
It's very, very simple.
And what I'm doing now, it's
finding where the event of
somebody eating the
button goes.
And it goes here.
Let me paste some code
that I have ready.
Where is that?
Here.
So I have an integer
that is the ID.
Can you read it, or
is it too small?
How is the size of the font?
Is it too small?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
fine.
LUCA MARTINETTI: That's fine?
OK.
So I have an integer that is
the triangle I've been
clicking on, and I just did the
small map of the colors.
So what I'm doing in-- oops.
Copy that--
so what I'm doing is creating
an event, and the
event looks like this.
As a timestamp, it's the custom
event that I'm calling
"beat." Maybe I can zoom
in a little bit.
It's an event that I'm
calling "beat."
As a value, it takes the color
of the ID I'm clicking on, and
I'm just adding two metadata.
One is the tile ID itself, and
I'm setting a flag that says
"green" if the ID is 12 or 15.
So this is how the ID is
of the different tiles.
What I need is just create the
event, and I have to put the
application ID here.
Oops, where was that?
Let me create a new application,
call it
GDC_beat01.
Now get an app ID, copy
that, switch to that.
Oops, other side.
And I paste it.
OK, here we go.
What I'll do is git commit,
gods help me--
and I'm pushing this
small demo.
Do a little dance, do
a little dance.
I never test my code.
Yeah, if you have iPhones and
iPads video, it would be nice
if you could go to this
URL that I'll
give you in one second.
That's live publishing--
come on, go there.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: It
works on laptops, too.
LUCA MARTINETTI: Demo gods,
are you helping me today?
OK.
In the meantime, I'll give
you the address.
Cleaning up, installing.
So it's happening.
Sorry for that.
I haven't found a faster way of
deploying my application.
OK, here we go.
So if we go to this URL here,
beat.staq.io, please do that.
It's not [INAUDIBLE] beat.
Do you have iPhones
or iPads video?
I have an iPad, maybe.
And just load the page.
OK, seven.
Seven of you guys are
on the page now.
I can see that.
Are you sending beats?
[INAUDIBLE]?
Are you playing?
I can't hear you very loud.
Turn up the volume.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: I want
to hear some more, too.
LUCA MARTINETTI: Want
to hear some more.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
We need big data.
LUCA MARTINETTI:
Is it loading?
This should be working on
iPhones and Androids as well.
But not--
[PERCUSSION SOUNDS]
LUCA MARTINETTI:
Is it working?
OK.
So you see the events flowing in
real time, and that's kind
of interesting, but not
super interesting.
So what I want to do, while you
bang on it, it's show you
that we can do custom queries.
So with the SQL syntax that I
was saying will be the same
for real time exploration for
all the historical data.
I can just say, SELECT COUNT the
distinct event ID from my
table where the event will be
"beat." And I want to do that
on the last minutes.
Yeah, you banged on it 2,000--
oh, almost 3,000 times.
OK, nice.
And since I'm storing the raw
data, and I'm against the raw
data, I can go down
to the second.
So if I'm lucky--
come on, guy.
Yeah.
That's very fresh data.
That's what's happening
in real time.
So if you stop playing-- stop
playing, guys, stop playing.
[LAUGHTER]
LUCA MARTINETTI: Stop it.
You'll miss my demo.
This will go down.
Here we go.
And at the same time, I add some
value that was a string
that I put with each single beat
that was the color, and I
say group by string.
Here we go.
All this mess here is the
different colors that you're
clicking on in real time.
So let's go green, everybody.
Let's start eating only
the green ones.
[PERCUSSION SOUNDS]
LUCA MARTINETTI: We should see
only the greens going up.
So imagine this is some real
data, and I'm showing, for
example, wins versus losses
for two specific classes.
So what I'm doing, I'm slicing
data in real time.
And this is quite nice because
I can go on different
resolutions in terms of time.
This is down by the second,
so it's more interactive.
But what is useful is that
I can see this data in my
dashboard, like all the rest.
So I can just pin this query and
see is our beats by color,
and I'll just add this
to my summary.
So when I go on my dashboard on
my Summary page, I'll have
it here like any other metrics
that are built in.
We'll enable more data
exploration without coding for
non-technical user with a query
builder, but the idea is
that since we're creating our
product on top of two very
powerful big data technologies,
we can go down
to the single event
every single time.
So adding features, slicing,
will be very,
very easy in the future.
I was imagining this to be more
loud than that, and I had
a "Harlem Shake" here.
["HARLEM SHAKE" PLAYING]
LUCA MARTINETTI: Having the beat
in the real time on top
of that, but you're
so shy, guys.
I was imagining all banging
on their iPads.
But that's fine.
So this was asking new question,
asking custom
question, to your data and try
to understand something.
Credit for the game goes
to this guy here.
Thank you.
The last step will be change
something, having
the option to react.
Once you understand something,
change it.
It can be a game design change
because you understand your
players are stuck at a certain
level or spending too much
time on a certain puzzle, or
it can be something like
reengaging players for a
specific cohort or trying some
hypothesis, like running a test
against a specific subset
and see how it goes.
This is something that I will
not show you today.
We're launching our beta, so if
you're interested in trying
Staq, please come talk to me.
Thanks again for Google for
having us, and if you have any
questions, we're
here to answer.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LUCA MARTINETTI:
Any questions?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: If you
guys have any questions,
please come up to the
microphone so we
can hear your question.
LUCA MARTINETTI: No questions?
OK.
Was very clear?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Yeah, I hope so.
So great.
So like you said, if you want
more information about either
of these products, staq.io and
developers.google.com/bigquery.
And it's easy to reach us there
as well, at least on the
Google side.
Join our Google+
page, the Cloud
Platform Developers page.
And we were asked to tell you
guys, please fill out your
mobile survey feedback.
The GDC is really interested
in that, as well.
Great.
We'll be up here until
the next session, so
thank you very much.
LUCA MARTINETTI: Just standing
and staring at you.
No pressure.